machine learning for biomedical data is
a series of asynchronous courses on rmix
logic that are focused on the logic and
application of machine learning and data
science for biomedical data starting
with the user-friendly tb info platform
and providing technical in-depth
overview of coding these methods in r
and python
this course in python will show how to
write the code and call various types of
analysis to wrangle visualize and
analyze data we will see how to apply
statistical methods of analysis and
prepare your data set for machine
learning or data mining we will also
cover applications of unsupervised and
supervised machine learning and provide
examples of deep learning models for
analysis classification feature
selection and visualization we'll review
the concepts behind a common challenge
in biomedical data finding signal and
noisy data sets and finding a biological
explanation for the results we will see
the challenges and opportunities on how
to use machine learning and find complex
molecular characteristics that can be
associated with a condition that we can
interpret
the course has several lessons on each
topic and is linked to example data sets
in various biomedical research domains
like cancer each lesson comes with a
practice console that you can use right
in the browser learning about the logic
syntax and testing your understanding
with hands-on exercises that have
predefined answers so you will be able
to check that you are actually getting
the right result that was intended for a
piece of code
in the section breakdown you will learn
about the objectives and strategies for
a given method then you will see how to
code the solution learning the syntax of
the code and then you will be able to
test your understanding with assignments
and coding challenges
once you understand how to write and
execute the code you will be given a
link to a jupyter notebook that you can
use as a starting point for submitting
the assignment checking that you are
getting the right results and that you
can address all of the challenges that
were explained in the lesson
assignments include technical as well as
conceptual examples where the methods
are going to be used for meaningful
analysis that you can use
so you will see how the same assignments
will be useful in your research projects
as you get involved deeper and deeper in
a particular domain
examples will showcase how some of these
popular techniques are used in real
research projects sourced from
peer-reviewed publications
so let's get started our first step
would be learning about the way to load
and prepare the data for analysis a task
that anyone has to master before getting
into the more complex analysis and
visualization methods that we will
discuss throughout the course